it's time for the lawn Jean chrono scope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene trauma scope Larry lisseur from the
CBS television news staff and August
texture chief editorial writer for The
New York Herald Tribune our
distinguished guest for this evening is
Jay earnest Wilkins Assistant Secretary
of Labor our guest tonight has had an
unusual career he was a prominent
practicing attorney in Chicago before he
became the first member of his race to
be appointed to sub cabinet rank and
already he's distinguished himself in
his first meeting with the Russians on
an international labor meeting mr.
Wilkins do you think that the fact that
you are a Negro is helpful to you in
these international labor conferences
yes mr. lisser I think it has helped me
a great deal you must remember the three
fourths of the people of the world are
non-white and I think it made a profound
impression upon the people from the rest
of the world when they recognize that
the United States of America had sent as
the head of its delegation any growth
but mr. Wilkins uh I don't think you've
ever been associated with the labor
union now do you consider that a
drawback in discussing these labor
problems in the international field no I
do not consider the drawback of toss a
matter of fact I think it has been an
asset because my mind has been open on
all questions affecting labor mr.
Wilkins of reference on the body that
you represented the united states in the
international labor organization had
recently met what does it do we can get
that state for the rate of event at the
International Labor Organization
commonly referred to as ILO is perhaps
the only international labor body that I
in a conference that i know that's
tripartite and its structure
there we have representatives of the
government representatives of management
and representatives of labor meeting in
a common forum and each speaks very
freely and independently upon all
matters that come before that body well
mr. Wilkins uh the Russians have
recently rejoined the international
labor organization and how does a labor
there treat its employers do you
differentiate in the international body
between labor and employer in Russia the
government know between the government
and the employer I think I don't even
more difficult that is one of the
principal objections raised to the
employer and employee delegates from
soviet russia and her satellites that
they have no such thing as free
employers are free employees and the
peculiar thing about it that I observed
at the conference was that at no time
during the conference did the employer
delegate or the employee delegate from
Russia are her satellites vote in a
different manner than the
representatives of the Russian
government on its settlement in the
American delegation tend to stick
together also in his views no the
frequently the government delegate from
the united states voted one way and the
employer delegate voted another way
frequently the employee delegated voted
contra to the way the delegate from the
government voted but the delegates from
soviet russia always voted solidly as a
block mr. Wilkins what is the
international labor organization trying
to do and how can the United States
supply itself to its aims Wow and the
primary objective of the ILO is to
improve their working conditions and
living conditions of laboring people we
recognize that the standards in the
United States of America are
considerably higher than they are in the
other nations of the world I mean
particularly the underdeveloped
countries of the world but it is to our
advantage to have working conditions
improved in those countries because as
working conditions are improved in the
other developed countries of the world
our working conditions are better that
is to say that the competition between
the workers
the other developed countries and our
and the United States of America are not
so keen there there were not a parallel
build it did Russia during this last
meeting of the International Labor
Organization show any tendency to
compromise or two or to go along with
the other countries or was it pretty
much in opposition Russia the delegates
from the Soviet countries never
compromised on anything they were had a
man in their positions of course they
pictured labor and soviet russia as
being a very fine thing but they never
compromise they took their position and
stood by even in defeat well did we ever
compromise on any of our positions mr.
Wilkins yeah I don't think we ever
compromised except in certain instances
when the matter came up of giving the
delegates from soviet russian or
satellites deputy positions on
committees we voted for that because
deputy on the committee's of the ILO all
they sat in all the meetings never had
any vote at all mr. Wilkers you think
that these overseas labor unions are
important factors in the great political
struggles of the Cold War I think the
labor unions overseas are very important
I think labor is one of the facets by
which we either spread our stop
communism where you have a satisfied
labor force I think you do not have a
fertile soil for communism to develop it
how would you evaluate the role of our
American labor unions in international
affairs and in regard to the ILO is work
I think our trade unions particularly
they have a valency io play a very
important role in developing better
relations between the working people of
the world certainly the labor unions of
the foreign countries are more kindly
disposed to listen to what is said by
American labor unions I think there's
some time suspicious of what the
delegates from the government say tell
them mr. Wilkins you think we're doing
enough to help and encourage the
labor movements overseas in the free
countries I don't think we're doing
everything that we opted to do it seems
to me when the feel of technical
assistance we are doing some things but
I think we ought to do considerably more
as you know mr. lisser that
three-fourths of the peoples of the
world and non-white and they sometimes
look with suspicion upon the attitude of
the American government we tried to
point out at the conference in Geneva
that the United States government
doesn't expect any particular favors
from a nation that it helps it only
helps these nations trying to make them
strong enough to be free but mr. will
there any exhibition is there anything
we can actually do that our government
could properly do to increase and
encourage labor organizations and other
countries I think we can do a number of
things the principle I think the thing I
think that we can do is to send labour
technicians particularly to the foreign
countries and where they might learn how
we operate between management and labor
wouldn't we make great enemies among
certain elements of management in those
countries I do not think if we make
enemies certainly there might be some
feeling of mistrust but generally I
think we've work in a good feel I don't
know whether you know it or not but we
have foreigners who come to the Labor
Department in Washington to study our
methods management relations between
labor and management we have them study
our field of workmen compensation law
and other laws so that they can go back
to their countries and try to put into
effect some of the principles which we
have established in this country mr.
Wilkins I was thinking about one of the
problems here what about segregation and
government work here aren't you a member
of a committee that is trying to do
something about that yes I am a member
of the president's committee on
government contracts which was
established by President Eisenhower in
august of 1953 and the primary function
of that committee is to see that there
are no discriminations in the matter of
employment where government contracts
are involved as you know they're perhaps
the 30 billion dollars worth of
contracts led by governmental agencies
every year and the purpose of this
committee to see that there's no
discrimination in the matter of
employment upgrading apprentice training
and so on in connection with these
government contracts have you been
effective as a committee you have no
powers I suppose is a matter motive
study and research I think committee has
been very effective we do not have any
penal powers of powers to enforce penal
sanctions but I think through the
governmental agencies and most of the
principal agencies are represented on
this committee the government
President's Committee on government
contracts has done a very effective work
it's been done very quietly but very
effectively mr. Wilkins it seems to me
that Ralph Bunche who is now the
Undersecretary of the United Nations
declined to take the very job in which
you now find yourself because he felt
that he didn't want to work in
Washington because perhaps his children
would be subject to segregation down
there now you have taken that job but do
you find that these conditions are
onerous to you dr. bunch was offered a
job as assistant secretary of state and
he did not want to come because he said
there was discrimination so far as the
schools were concerned as a matter of
fact mr. Lister during the past 20
months a great many changes have taken
place in the city of Washington there's
no discrimination so far as hotel
accommodations are concerned no
discrimination in restaurants and other
public facilities I do not say and now
that Supreme Court has passed on the
matter of the segregation in public
schools integration will start in the
Washington public schools on next Monday
the 13 Washington is a much different
place than it was 20 months ago in other
words the ticket that you feel your race
has something to be thankful for during
these Labor Day anniversaries area we
think the entire American public has
something to be thankful for because
this decision of the Supreme Court made
all Americans free well thank you very
much mr. welcome to the great pleasure
to have you here
night the opinions expressed on the lawn
teen chrono scope were those of the
speaker's the editorial board for this
edition of the lawn gene chrono scope
was Larry lesser and August texture our
distinguished guest was Jay earnest
Wilkins assistant secretary of labor